- Hello, this is Brian Tracy
I wanted to thank Evan
for making this video
about my advice on goal setting
and sharing these important
messages with his audience.
- Hello, Believe Nation,
my name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe, and
I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all of the major
problems in the world.
I started the MentorMe
series with the goal
to try to hang around people who've done
a lot more than us, and
hopefully by spending more time
with them, some of their
mindset, their thoughts,
their beliefs, their
attitudes, their way of looking
at the world seeps into
us to help us become
the best version of ourselves.
So today we're going to
learn from Brian Tracy
and some of his goal-setting advice.
Mentor me, Brian.
Rule number five is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always, guys, as you're watching,
if somebody says something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired.
And when you write it
down, it's much more likely
to stick for yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(upbeat music)
- In order to be successful,
you must have one big goal.
I give goal-setting
exercise all over the world
that is life-changing.
I go back a year a later,
or two years later,
or three years later, and
I have thousands of people
come up to me, almost
like a guru or a sage,
and they say, you changed
my life, you made me rich.
And I said it was the goals, wasn't it?
And they said, yes, it was
the goals, how did you know?
And what I teach is this,
is take a piece of paper,
make a list of 10 goals that
you would like to achieve
in the next 12 months.
These are one-year goals.
Now sometimes, I'll have
a one-day, a one-week,
a one-month, three months, six months,
but they're all goals that
you want to accomplish
within 12 months.
Then you look over this list, and you say,
if I could wave a magic wand
and achieve any one goal
on this list, within 24 hours,
which one goal would have
the greatest positive impact
on my life.
And then you look at your list of 10,
and the answer will jump out at you.
And that becomes your
major definite purpose.
This because your major goal.
Then you transfer this to
a clean sheet of paper,
and you write a deadline, when you want
to achieve this goal.
You make a list of everything
that you could think of
that you could do to achieve this goal.
You then organize this
list like a checklist,
in order of sequence,
what do you do first,
what do you do second,
what do you do third?
And then you take action on your goal,
and then you do something
on that goal every day,
seven days a week.
It's a very simple system,
decide the most important goal,
write it down, make a
plan, work on it every day.
And then all of your other goals
will start to move forward.
You'll start to make
progress on the big goal,
but all of the other goals
will start to move forward
almost without you even
paying attention to them.
So that's really the key to
success, is single focus.
Warren Buffett and Bill
Gates were at a dinner party
with Bill Gates' father and a
large number of other people,
at Bill Gates' home in Seattle last year.
And they were chatting with
each other, they're very good
friends, and somebody
came up to them and said,
excuse, gentlemen, I don't
mean to interrupt you,
but you're three of the most
important, most successful
people in the world, Bill
Gates and Warren Buffett
are number one, number two
wealthiest men in the world.
What would you say is the most
important ingredient for success?
And they all stopped and
broke off their conversation,
and all turned simultaneously and looked
at the man and said, focus.
Focus is the most important
quality for success.
If you can focus, you can do anything.
If you can't focus, you must always work
for someone else who will make you focus.
Now wonderfully enough, focusing is like
learning how to ride a bicycle
or type with a keyboard.
It's a learnable skill.
You can learn to focus by practicing
focus until it becomes automatic.
One of my favorite quotes is from Goethe,
the German philosopher, and he said,
"Everything is hard before it's easy."
So the formation of any new habit
is hard before it's easy.
You have to keep working at it.
It's just like a bicycle.
You keep falling down,
you have to keep getting
back up again, until finally
it becomes easier and easier,
and soon it becomes automatic.
And when you automatically
get up each day, plan your day
and work on your most important goal,
your whole life will transform.
- So here's some guidelines
for writing your goals.
First, make sure you write
them in the present tense
as if your goal had already been achieved.
For example, instead of saying I will earn
X amount of dollars each year,
write I earn X dollars each year.
The reason that we do this is
because your subconscious mind
can only register
commands that are phrased
in the present tense.
Next, write your goals
in the positive sense.
So instead of saying, I will quit smoking,
you would write, I am a nonsmoker.
Finally, write your goals
in the personal tense.
In other words, all of your goals
should start with the word I.
This is the only way that
your subconscious recognizes
that this is a command
coming from the head office,
is when you say I, plus an action verb
in the positive sense.
I earn X number of dollars this year.
- There's a process which
has made more people rich
than any other single
process of goal achieving,
and it's to take your major goal
and structure it as a question.
If your goal is to earn $100,000 a year,
then you write, how can I earn $100,000
in the next 12 months?
Now that's an open-ended question,
not how can I earn it at my
job or doing a specific thing.
Just an open-ended question,
how can I earn the amount of money?
And then you discipline to write
20 answers to the question.
And the 20 answers are
all the different things
that you can think of to earn $100,000.
Work longer, work harder,
upgrade my skills,
get a new job, take a
part-time opportunity,
whatever it happens to be.
Write down everything you could think of,
but force yourself to write
at least 20 questions,
or 20 answers to the question.
The 20-question method,
called mind storming,
forces you to dig deep
deep into your mind,
where you will find all your answers.
And it may be call a person, read a book.
Let me give you an example.
We had a young fellow,
entrepreneur, 35 years old.
He had built a successful business,
he worked about 10 years to do it.
And he for two years
wanted to sell his business
so he could take a year off
and travel, enjoy his money.
And so for two years he just
sort of floundered around,
like a fish on the dock,
wanting to sell his business.
Nobody offered to buy it.
He suggested it to people,
people were not interested
and so on, and in this exercise
that they put him through,
his 20th answer, and
often it's the 20th answer
that is the breakthrough, was
buy a book on how to
sell your own business.
And it just went off like
a flashbulb in his mind.
At the break, he got up.
It was a downtown hotel, got up,
went down the street to a major bookstore,
went and found, he was
amazed at the number
of books that had been written on how
to buy and sell a business.
So he bought two or three books.
Two months later, he had restructured,
packaged his business, sold it completely,
satisfactorily and took a year off.
He said, but it was just a single idea.
It was a breakthrough
idea, but it was so simple.
Just get a book on the subject.
And you think, boy, that's pretty obvious.
Yes, but it's the most obvious
answers that we overlook.
- One of the most valuable
exercises you can engage in
when setting goals is to ask yourself,
what is my limiting step?
What is the one factor
that determines the speed
at which I achieve my goal?
Or whether I achieve it at all
throughout my personal development?
Your ability to identify
your limiting step
is one of the best demonstrations
of your intelligence and a step
toward building self-confidence.
Your capacity to eliminate
this limiting step
is one of the best demonstrations
of your overall competence in
achieving anything you want.
In studying everything that
has been written or said
about personal development and success,
the conclusion I came
to was that your level
of self-confidence is
probably the critical
factor in everything you'll accomplish.
When you have enough self-confidence,
you will try almost anything.
Because success is largely
a matter of averages
or probabilities, the more things you try,
the more likely it is that
you will achieve greatly.
The same is true for you.
By setting goals, trying more things,
engaging in more activities,
and exploring more opportunities,
your probabilities of success
increase dramatically.
The only real limiting
step that you might have
is your level of self-confidence.
When you reach the point
at which you believe
in yourself absolutely,
the barriers that exist
in your external world will not stop you.
The major obstacles to success always lie
within the mind of the individual.
They are not contained in external
circumstances or situations or people.
By building self-confidence,
you win the inner battle.
The outer battle seems
to take care of itself.
I've learned three important ideas
for building self-confidence.
First, accept complete
responsibility for yourself
and for everything that
you are and ever will be.
Second, accept that you
can change your situation
only by going to work on yourself
and learning the things you need to know
in order to be better.
Third, setting goals with
timelines for the things
that you want, and then
working on them every day
to bring those goals into reality builds
your self-confidence.
- Many years ago, at a talk,
I was speaking to Rich DeVos
when he was on his way up.
Rich DeVos, the president of Amway,
worth $5.3 billion today.
Started off knocking
on doors, selling soap.
And he was working his
way up, and I asked him,
I said, what have you found,
what's the most important
quality of successful people?
And he said, Brian, he said
we found there's a direct
relationship, I still
remember him telling me this,
between how quickly a person
takes action on a new idea
and how likely it is they
will ever take action
on any idea at all.
And so the action orientation
is the critical thing.
We watch people, everybody
hears the same things,
they hear the same
ideas, but then we watch
and we see how quickly they take action.
And if a person takes action
quickly on a new idea,
the chances are they're
going to be successful
go up by hundreds of percent.
Now what most people do is
they say, that's a great idea,
it's a wonderful idea, I love
it, I'm going to do that,
ooh, I'm so excited.
But before I apply it, I
need to take a vacation.
(laughter)
To a wonderful place called Someday Isle.
And so they go to Someday Isle
and they live on Someday Isle.
And who are they surrounded
with on Someday Isle?
Other people on Someday Isle.
And what is the chief topic of
conversation on Someday Isle?
Yes, it's their excuses.
What's your excuse for not taking action?
What's your excuse for
not getting in on it?
What's your excuse for not losing weight,
getting out of debt,
building your business,
writing your book, getting
your book finished,
getting your damn book started?
You know, in other words,
what's your excuse,
and all share excuses.
Oh, that's a good excuse,
I haven't used that one
for a long time.
That'll take me another year.
And so what they do is they sit around,
and the bottom 80% of the population
lives on Someday Isle most of their lives.
They all have these great resolutions
and these wonderful intentions,
but what's the road to hell paved with?
It's good intentions, and
I'm going to do that someday,
Someday Isle, so rule number for success
is whatever you learn here,
vote yourself off the island.
(laughter)
No more Someday Isle,
either do it or don't do it.
- Prepare in advance.
You know, the old saying,
proper prior preparation
saves poor performance or
prevents poor performance.
The six P's.
And so prepare your work
list for the following day
the evening or the night before.
The last thing you do
at the end of the day
is you lay out the day that's coming.
The best exercise is for you
to plan your entire next day
as the last thing you do
before coming home from work.
When you plan your day the night before,
your subconscious mind then goes to work
on your plans and goals
while you're asleep.
Very often, you'll wake up in the morning
with ideas and insights that
apply to the work of the day.
Now a major benefit of
preparing your daily list
the night before is that this exercise
lets you sleep more soundly.
A major reason for insomnia
is people lying awake
trying not to forget
to remember everything
that they have to do the following day.
But once you've written down
everything that you have
to do on the list, it clears your mind
and enables you to sleep deeply.
This will help you
increase your productivity
throughout the whole next day of work
because you'll be more
relaxed and more refreshed.
Give yourself a reward of some kind
for practicing the new behavior.
Each time you reward
yourself, you reaffirm
and reinforce that behavior.
Soon, you begin to associate
at an unconscious level
the pleasure of the
reward with the behavior.
You set up your own force
field of positive consequences,
that you unconsciously look forward to
as a result of engaging
in that behavior or habit
that you've decided upon.
- So what do you think holds people back?
They know what they want to do,
but they just can't keep the habit.
They do it once, and then
they fall of the train,
and then next month they do it again
and they fall off the train.
How do you make that consistent?
- Well, you just keep working
at it and working at it.
The best way of all is
to plan it in advance.
Instead of sitting down, never
start work without a list,
and never start work with
prioritizing your list.
People sit down, and they say,
well, before I make a list
I'll check a little email,
check a little spam,
send something to my friends,
see what's going on YouTube,
and so on and so forth,
and then they look up and it's 10 o'clock.
And they haven't done anything of value.
So what you do is you have to say,
you know,
well, you know, what do they say,
if you start it right
it'll work out right?
So start it on your most important task.
And do that until it becomes a habit.
And here's an interesting
thing about checking email,
is when you check email
it triggers the release
of dopamine in your brain.
Dopamine is a drug.
By the way, there's all
kinds of books and articles
and scientific studies on this.
And dopamine is the same drug in cocaine.
And what it does, is
it's triggered every time
you have a shiny object, or something new
or different or interesting or sparkling.
If a telephone rings next
to you, you go, bing,
your brain releases endorphins,
and you can't hardly
wait to see what it is.
You're talking to somebody,
and you could be talking
to somebody about something very serious,
and your telephone goes off, bing.
Your whole mind goes blank.
The middle of the conversation stops.
You grab for your phone, you pick it up,
you look at it, you check
it out and everything else,
and then you come back.
If you're working on a
task, it takes an average
of 17 minutes to get back to the task.
And then there's another distraction,
so another 17 minutes.
Average adult is checking
their email and their phone
between 95 and 145 times a day.
- That's crazy.
- Which means they're like
attention deficit disorder dogs,
just running around back
and forth the whole day.
At the end of the day, they're exhausted.
By the way, USA Today
and Harvard have proved
that you lose one IQ point for every hour
that you leave your email on.
At the end of the day,
you've lost 10 IQ points.
You actually become stupider
throughout the day, dumber.
And I ask this of my audience as I say,
Have you every finished a day
where you don't think you've
accomplished anything?
You've been on email
responding to bings and beeps
and rings and so on all day,
and at the end of the day you go home,
and honey says, what
do you want for dinner?
And you say, I don't know, I don't care.
Anything, I just want a drink.
Because you're so exhaust,
you cannot even decide.
You sit there, and basically
like you've just been
punched in the side of the head.
Because your brain is dead,
and you lose 10 IQ points.
You get stupider throughout the day.
You've got to turn that darn thing off
if you want to remain sharp.
Develop the habit.
You say, I'm going to develop the habit,
and I'm going to give myself my reward,
and my reward will be to check my email
after I finish my first task.
So all of success in
life is task completion.
Let me repeat that.
I just had a long conversation
with an entrepreneur
and he almost fell of his chair.
I was coaching him.
And he said he never heard that before.
And then I spoke to this group
I was telling you in Japan.
I told them the same thing,
and they were just flabbergasted.
Is the key to success in
life is task completion.
If you don't complete
tasks, you have no future.
And so if task completion is the key,
then what you do is you complete
more and more important tasks.
And if you start every day by completing
the most important task,
your brain actually releases endorphins.
Now endorphins is another chemical,
and it's only released
when you do something
that is life-enhancing,
and what that means is,
when you do something
that is good for you,
that enhances your
life, that furthers you,
it makes you happy.
It releases energy, it
raises your self-esteem.
I sort of say, if you want to be a winner,
how do you be a winner, well you win.
And winning means you cross a finish line.
So if you start and complete a task,
you're actually winning.
And you get a feeling of being a winner,
which gives you an infusion of energy,
and inspiration, and it
drives you and motivates you
to want to get that feeling again.
So how do you get that feeling again?
You start and complete another task.
So I've developed the habit,
and people who are successful
develop the habit of starting
and completing tasks.
So my wife comes in and says
dinner's in five minutes,
so I look at my list, and I say, okay,
there's a five-minute task.
And I'm going to start and
complete a five-minute task.
And each time you complete a task,
you get a burst of endorphin.
The bigger the task, the more endorphin.
The more endorphin, the more
quickly you become addicted
to starting and completing
important tasks.
And every single successful
person has a reputation
for starting and
completing important tasks.
You want the job done,
give it to him or her.
You want the product served on time,
you want the product completed,
you want the product
manufactured, shipped, delivered,
give it to him, give it to
her, give it to that company,
because they always deliver.
That's the best reputation you can have
if you want to get rich.
- Hello, this is Brian Tracy.
I wanted to thank Evan
for making this video
about my advice on goal setting
and sharing these important
messages with his audience.
I also want to encourage
each of you to use
the advice here to take
action on achieving your goals
and pursuing your dreams
instead of living on Someday Isle.
Someday, I'll do this,
someday, I'll do that.
But you never do it.
Take action, and take action now.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know, what did
you think of this video?
What was your favorite clip and why?
What lesson are you going
to pull from this clip
and immediately apply somehow to your life
or to your business?
Please leave it down
in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a
quick shoutout of Nathan
from the Productivity Game Channel.
Nathan, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and making
that awesome YouTube video
review on it.
I really appreciate the support, man,
and I'm glad you enjoyed the book.
- [Nathan] Carmichael states
that there is one word
that defines who you are,
connects all the things
in your life that make you come alive
and will help you escape
the chains of mediocrity.
- So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.